nord stream 1 liefert nur noch 20 gas
der russische konzern gazprom senkt die
lieferungen durch die ostseepipeline
nord stream 1 weiter von mittwoch an
würden noch 20 prozent oder anders
gesagt 33 millionen kubikmeter gas
täglich durch die wichtigste
versorgungsleitung nach deutschland
fließen
nochmal in etwa der hälfte der schon
zuvor durch gazprom auf 40
turbinen so heißt es offiziell und auch
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
wird uns auf einen harten winter ein
putin nutze die mittel die er hat das
ist ja keine neue situation und auch in
keinster weise überraschend seit anfang
des jahres ist dieses szenario eine
ernste bedrohung und das ist auch häufig
genug in talkshows und den
nachrichtensendungen erklärt und
beschrieben worden wir sind darauf
vorbereitet aber es ist natürlich eine
ernste situation
also wenn jetzt irgendjemand überrascht
ist und sagt wir sind abhängig von
russischem gas und putin könnte es
einsetzen dann hat ja was haben sie denn
das letzte halbe jahr gemacht wir sind
in einer ernsten situation ist wird auch
zeit dass alle verstehen dass wir dieses
gefühl von na ja es ist sommer als wird
schon nicht so schlimm kommen endlich
ablegen wir müssen die gasverbraucher
runter bringen daran arbeiten wir daran
haben wir die ganze zeit gearbeitet und
wie geht s weiter nehmen unser maßnahmen
konsequent umsetzen und dieses land
zusammen steht und sagt ja putin hat das
gas aber wir haben die kraft bei uns im
studio unser bild politik chef jan
schäfer schönen guten morgen janka lemgo
hbk schlägt alarm aber eigentlich ist er
ja derjenige der jetzt handeln müsste
müsste er jetzt nicht also die
kehrtwende einleiten das interessant was
robert habe gesagt hat gestern abend der
hat gesagt die lage ist ernst und hat
gesagt das muss jetzt eigentlich jeder
verstehen
und das kann man auch als appell von
robert habeck an sich selbst und an die
grüne partei auf fassen denn am ende
geht es um die frage wie schaffen wir es
dass wir weniger gas nutzen weniger gas
verbrauchen beispielsweise in der
stromerzeugung gerade was den winter
angeht und diese lücke auffüllen
beispielsweise durch kernenergie und das
war bei dem kern thema um das es auch
heute gehen wird in brüssel beim
sondergipfel der eu energie minister da
wird robert habeck auch anwesend sein es
geht um die frage wie sparen wir
einerseits gas und es wird massiven
druck auf deutschland geben das hören
wir jetzt schon zu sagen aber wenn
andere europäische länder gast sparen
sollen dann müsst ihr liebe deutsche
bitte auch eure drei letzten
kernkraftwerke am netz lassen was
erwartest du von diesem eu-energiegipfel
ich meine es in aller munde jeder guckt
hin natürlich erwartet man dann
natürlich auch heute ergebnisse was kann
da rauskommen das was bis jetzt vorab
durchgesickert ist folgt ist es gab ja
von
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen ein
vorschlag dass die eu-staaten insgesamt
15 prozent gas einsparen sollen ab
august bis zum kommenden märz da gab es
massiven widerstand von zahlreichen
länder unter anderem spanien portugal
griechenland malta und jetzt hat man
sich geeinigt auf einen freiwilligen
verzicht und das ganze wird auch nicht
mehr mit einstimmiger mehrheit
beschlossen werden müssen sondern nur
noch mit rund der hälfte der stimmen
beziehungsweise von ländern die
mindestens 65 prozent der einwohner in
der eu aus marl das heißt man hat den
vorschlag von ursula von der leyen
deutlich abgemildert es soll zu
einsparungen kommen das ist das eine was
heute beschlossen wird andererseits und
das hören wir beispielsweise aus ländern
wie den niederlanden gibt es massiven
druck auf robert habeck die
kernkraftwerke über den jahreswechsel
hinaus laufen zu lassen das heißt
deutschland wird von den anderen
eu-staaten ordentlich in die zange
genommen ganz genau wir hören das ja
auch aus der eigenen koalition haben
gestern gesprochen unter anderem mit dem
fdp fraktionsvorsitzenden christian dürr
wir haben gesprochen mit dem
energiepolitischen sprecher der fdp
michael kruse der beispielsweise sagt
wir sollten die kernkraftwerke bis
frühjahr 2024 laufen lassen und
christian dürr der fdp-fraktionschef die
er sagt zum beispiel
wir fordern europäische solidarität was
das thema senkung des gasverbrauchs
angeht aber dann müssen wir natürlich
auch europäische solidarität zeigen und
forderungen nach längeren akw-laufzeiten
nachgeben das bedeutet es steht alles
eigentlich auf längere akw-laufzeiten
hier in deutschland besten dank herrn
schäfer
[Musik]